if we solve it in this way would this be
something that would be convenient for
you to use
right and well and we always try to
think you know coming from from a
development background like would i be
okay with it like if if the organization
that i worked at
would have implemented this solution
would i have any objection as a
developer in the organization and we try
to make sure that it would be solutions
that we would also want to use and that
they don't cause any you know
um
inconvenience to the developers that
that's always something you would want
to avoid and we want to let the
developers continue to work fluidly
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jvengers a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opus labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec welcome to 20 minute leaders
where back to engineering meet ronnie
slavin co-founder and cto of sci code
ronan is the co-founder and cto of
scicode a startup that secures software
delivery pipelines and provides full
visibility into enterprise development
infrastructure a serial entrepreneur and
former unit 8200 officer of the israel
defense forces prior to cyclode ronan
co-founded philoc which was acquired by
reason security in 2018 where he led the
research and endpoint protection
development
bonanza welcome to 20 minute leaders how
are you
i'm great michael how are you good i'm
excited that you're great because we're
going to have a really fun and energetic
20-minute conversation and what you're
working on with sci code is co-founder
and cto i think is is really important
and it's important not just because
you're solving an important pain point
but i think it's an interesting example
of how a market is developing a new
profession is developing over a very
short period of time and and and we're
introducing a new complexity of user
experience and consumer behavior that
with sci code you're looking to to to
help fix and help resolve and and help
developer development teams become
better obviously we know that pretty
much every company in the world now is
becoming a tech company because software
is eating the world and and obviously if
you're helping make software better then
then psycho is destined to eat the world
hopefully
tell me a little bit about yourself
okay cool so i am ronan i'm 33 years old
i live in tel aviv
and
basically you know been fascinated with
computers since i was a
kid
so actually actually i started my first
degree during high school um
sort of in the in the open university
and
then when i was 18 i i pushed my army
service for a year to to finish the
degree
i worked in that time
uh actually i got my first job as a
developer at the company called delta
yeah so they developed like their radar
system for the iron drone yeah i don't
know so it was a
a really cool job to have at 18.
and
then after a year i joined the army i
was drafted to 2800
and
i did there in total about a little more
than five and a half years
i started as a developer then i went to
officer course i came back
started leading leading a team
growing it
and also did my masters in computer
science during the army at that time
and
then after this five and a half years i
left to travel a little bit came back
and looked for my
to my second job as a civilian
and so i started working at a tenniso
group it was about
seven years ago six years ago
seven
and so many doing a research there for a
year and a half
and then i left and opened
my first startup that was called the
firelock
um the idea was that any device can be
hacked so we wanted to build a solution
that can protect data even if their
device is hacked
uh so we ran for about two years uh
after that we were acquired by a company
called reason
and they developed a
windows endpoint protection solution for
the consumer market
and so i moved there and i worked on the
on the windows endpoint protection and
and
and the research
had reason
and
and then after about a year and a half
also i left an open cycle and it was
about two years ago
um
and i'm still working on it
and working the company yeah
very very cool uh
so software
and
you know tell me a little bit from your
perspective
what what has been happening you've
you've been developing for quite some
time and coding for quite some time
what has how how has this industry
evolved
over the years to the point where we're
at now where cycled is relevant
so so there's all kinds of factors that
contributed to it obviously the first
one you mentioned the software is it in
the world like if we look at any company
that became huge and any company that
is sort of still relevant um that they
all the only companies that have very
large development uh organizations so
even if you look at mcdonald's and
things like that they also
do a lot of development and they invest
in it a lot and this this is how they
sort of uh evolve
uh to stay relevant and um
and that's one contributing factor to
why software is hitting the world so
that's one thing that happened
um and then if you look at the other
trends that happen so there's uh
there's this devops trends or or a
githubs
and
that sort of change the way that
the way that we develop software
uh so if you if you look at the
companies like jfrog they like their
phrases make software development liquid
yeah so so it kind of changed like the
the classic approach where you had like
the development environment that was
separated and then like you had a
different environment for testing and
you had all these
manual transitions between the
environments and and all these general
controls because of the processes that
were there
um
that now we don't have them like the
moment that you do something in the
development environment the sole notion
of github kicks in and it takes what you
what you just merge builds it
test it make sure that everything is
okay and it pulls it to production
so some of the barriers that we had
between the stations are no longer there
um
so now like first of all the developers
they have much more power
like if you if you are able to merge
into let's say something that goes to
production so you simply
can go through all the processes
so i think these are the main two
factors that that basically
you know made made the importance of
protecting
software development environments and
software delivery pipelines
and made it much more important
and then like we got evidence over the
past years with many
attacks that targeted these specific uh
scenarios and these specific processes
so what i'm hearing you and i just want
to make sure that i'm that i understood
this correctly you're saying there's two
contributing trends too you know the
origination of cyclone one of them is
the simple idea that software is eating
the world and we can all agree on that
that even that not just the new
companies are they are software based
but also the the incumbents are now
transitioning to technology and we can
see that from big pharma to to retail
chains all the way to
insurance companies right and then the
second contributing factor that you're
mentioning is the fact that software
developers are becoming much more
autonomous and independent
having the power to deploy code
themselves to production especially as
we're transitioning from monolith to
microservices and so software developers
there's not as many checks and balances
if you will along the supply chain from
from the ide all the way to the
production correct
yeah and obviously there's lots of
benefits to it i mean you know if you
want to fix the bug in production you
can do it in a matter of seconds and you
don't need to wait for a
very tiring process and on the other end
like we need to make sure that we you
know we we give them the enough
protection and enough uh
[Music]
tools to be able to protect themselves
and not to expose like the product or
the code or whatever makes that makes a
lot of sense now
tell me you know you're so you're
understanding this and you're sitting
you know with leo and with the team and
you're figuring out okay what in the
world are we gonna how are we gonna
solve this is is the product you know
you know do you all agree on on what you
need to be doing or is there you know a
discussion or ideation around this
so we started with you know sort of
brainstorming and getting getting a lot
of ideas on on if we want to solve you
know there's there's lots of issues with
with securing like software development
and
and related systems and obviously
there's lots of solutions and lots of
directions that that you can take so we
start with brainstorming ideas
but then
the immediate thing we do after that is
we start talking to
relevant clients people that work in
security teams and organizations that
have software development
that have software development processes
um and we asked them like is is this is
this uh a concern for you is this a pain
point if we solve it in this way would
this be something that would be
convenient for you to use
right and well and we always try to
think you know coming from from a
development background like would i be
okay with it like if if the organization
that i worked at
would have implemented this solution
would i have any objection as a
developer in the organization and we try
to make sure that
it would be solutions that we would also
want to use and that they don't cause
any you know
um
inconvenience to the developers that
that's always something you would want
to avoid and
we want to let the developers continue
to to work fluidly and without
interrupting them by the way how you
know in
i'm i know that i'm jumping around a
little bit but if we're looking at the
world of product led growth and
you know you're building
you're building a tool for developers by
developers how do you what are some of
the checks and balances that you have
for yourself
as you know cto but but a leader in this
organization to make sure that
developers do like the product that
you're building that it's not something
that you know they're resisting to as it
enters organizations
uh so obviously you know as a startup
these are things that uh we sort of we
mature at uh yeah
so first of all the main approach that
we took is that um
like we don't wanna teach developers to
use a new product we wanna integrate
with the tools that they already use and
really if you look at if you look at the
platform that's that's already out there
like look if you look at github for
example right like they have they
already have like a mechanism that you
can comment and you can interact and
there is like emojis i don't know
whatever things like that and get github
the emojis changed the whole the whole
experience i have to say
to me it's gifts i'm waiting for gifts
to get to get them
um so so we look at it and we say okay
let's try to use this existing
these existing capabilities and and work
with them instead of like creating a
product that now the developers need to
learn and then i need to log into and
visit every once in a while so really
collaborate with them
and obviously it also ties back to what
i mentioned earlier that we we simply
asked them we we talked to the security
teams we
um
we asked them to to or to work with the
developers i think it's also one of the
trends that we see
for example if you look at cubecon which
was uh last time last month so there was
a lot of security in it in a conferences
that sort of the the origin of it is
more it's more devops or more
development and
it's becoming clear that like security
is not something that you can you know
isolate from the developers it's
something that's becoming a part of
development itself
um
and something that that
we all are understanding right now and
we see the products responding
accordingly going back to the to the the
idea of
you know developers you know
having to take more ownership of their
security as you're building psycho
you're watching the organization grow
from pretty much you know few people to
now you mentioned 50 people more than
half of them as engineers
you as a technology leader how have you
evolved do you think since the inception
of sitecode up until now
so to me i think like first of all it's
you know hiring very strong people like
obviously obviously it's um
i'm not objective but uh like hiring top
top talent and having smart people
uh surround you and and
and in the company
and
we're very open
at cycle like we always want to we
always want to hear
everyone's opinion
i mean
eventually we develop a product for
developers and we have developers in the
organization so
they have a lot of
obviously they can they can contribute a
lot to the product it's not something
that is foreign to them it's something
that they live daily and and they and
they all
have really good ideas and
and probably there will be like the best
um you know people to listen to when
when we build this product
um so which we try to we try to lean on
that as much as we can
and obviously
um
you know being
trying to keep this open mentality and
just like you know sharing uh sharing
whatever we can
even connecting them with clients
whenever possible
um really closing this feedback here
quick
and if you're looking internally with
you and the engineers that
you hire and that you manage
you know what what how do you see
yourself as a tech leader what are some
of the guiding you know the north star
for you
as in your communication and your
decision making
so so there's all kinds of aspects uh
related to building the product so um
again it's a it's a different discussion
of like the responsibilities of the cto
versus the vp rnd and like how to divide
divided responsibilities
um
we have we have a very strong heavy prnd
here that he leads the iron dribble the
rnd rnd group and
you know obviously we started with some
some initial architecture but
is his leading and he's like that since
then and my part is more to sort of
follow the trends in the market um
a lot of the
a lot of the activity that happened over
the past year if we if we look at 2021
so there were
really critical incidents that involved
the software supply chain so solarwinds
is the first one is you know this is how
the year started then you had cold call
you had an injection attack to php
there's all kinds of
um
really devastating attacks that happened
through the software supply chain and uh
and the entire industry is now talking
about what would be a possible solution
there's a framework that google is
starting to develop right now that it's
called salsa that that is more like
guidelines and things like that uh on
what you should do and how you should
build the provenance but i i try to
follow like the trends on that
understand where the market is going
where the industry is going and then how
we can incorporate it into the product
um
so that's sort of how we divide it
well then take me back before the open
university you know before
you become an engineer middle school
elementary school you know 10 years old
what what and what you know where's your
mind at what makes you curious what
fascinates you as a kid
uh so i like to learn a new stuff um and
uh i'm originally from much dawn if you
know the
probably you know
so obviously there's there's a
there there were all kinds of programs
you know for for children so i think it
was a major contributor like you go
every friday and you know we we had some
robotics with some even japanese and
things like that um but eventually the
technical aspect is what uh
is what i got
you know sucked into the most
and obviously i think you know as a kid
you're not
you don't make your decisions on your
own obviously you know my parents they
were a major contributor and
um
probably you know one of the one of the
main reasons that i that i did it and
and i have to thank them for that it's
it saves me a lot of time in the future
and if you look today at where you draw
your inspiration from you wake up every
day and you go
to to lead psycho what you know where do
you derive your inspiration so so first
of all i i really enjoy it i enjoy
working with the people in psycho and i
enjoy working on the product it's it's
super interesting to me so
to me like the inspiration come with
with like from working with awesome
people and
just really enjoying coming to work
every day and
believing that the problem that we're
trying to solve is critical uh to us we
got the proof this year we opened cycle
there about
more than a year before solar winds and
before cod cove and a lot of the
a lot of the
discussion that we see right now
are things that we were you know talking
about
uh i don't know a year and a half ago
and it's it's a really great validation
for us to see it coming from you know
well-known organizations like gartner
and
google and i don't know
nist and things like that
uh so to me this this combo of having
awesome people with you and um
really believing that you're solving an
important issue
is what drives me i love it and three
words you would use to describe yourself
four two or four
or two three or four
um
so i'm a
technology technology
junkie yeah
um
so that's that's the words um but also
i'd love to i'd love to uh
enjoy and have fun because we did it too
best of luck with sci code i think it's
you know an amazing timing it's an it's
a real pain point that you know it's
literally i think just the concept of
understanding how software is hitting
the world and and the the ripple effect
that it's going to have on our
methodologies and the way that we work
just like you know i'm looking back at
the industrial revolution and how people
all of a sudden were placed by machines
and the way that now you develop
machines is changing and and how you
have these inflection points where
checks and balances have to be mitigated
and and you have that distance between
optimization for speed and efficiency
but also the ability to make sure that
you're doing everything properly and and
and i think it's just an exciting
exciting time to be an engineer an
exciting time to to lead a company like
sci code so best of luck and i can't
wait to follow the journey and thank you
for the time
yeah i agree completely and thank you
for having me
i really enjoyed every great day as well
thank you very much